Anthony when we look at your IMDB
credits okay so we're gonna see one
acting credit in 2010 one in 2012 then
in 2013 6 2014 8 and now 2015 ding ding
ding 13 credits do you attribute that to
improving your craft or shift in your
attitude or neither oh I would say a lot
us do with location okay and those first
ones were actually stuff that I wrote
and produced myself so like 2010 2012 so
in a way I don't really it's not that I
don't count them I didn't even know that
I feel cool right now I mean that's also
good let it sink in I think it does I
think that's a little bit to do with
just meeting more people and you know
I've worked with it's all six degrees of
Kevin Bacon for everyone out here really
you go from working on that first
feature I did I got called in from the
same director six months later just to
do a day roll on his next feature and
then because that did a voiceover on his
next feature just because they had a
previous relationship but anyways I
think it is an attribute to yeah like
you said having a different mentality
and a different kind of set plan but
it's also because I've been doing more
things so I'm meeting new people and I'm
seeing more casting directors and I'm I
went to a friend's show she was doing a
musical and I got talking to one of the
guys that was in it and he was from
Michigan and we ended up having a couple
friends in common and then lo and behold
you know two weeks later because he
looked at my social media he saw my real
and he's like I'm doing a brand new
project I'd love for you to come in and
read for this so it's just a matter of
getting your name out there a little bit
more and a lot of it you know the old
the oldest improv rule in the book say
yes a and and just be thankful for what
you have in front of you and do what you
can because you know there's a lot of
projects that I'm sure either people
there's snuff their noses too or didn't
want to do things you know a few years
back because it wasn't as big as they
would have liked it to be or they felt
like they had just take a step back but
it's like people that are making stuff
like that in five years they're going to
be making
big stuff so it's good to just say yes
to people and meet people and I'm still
happy about the credits going up alright
it's still happy about that
so you tributed to just getting out
there I do I think it's a lot of just
saying yes and just going on all day I
mean there everyone's done it where
they've gone on an audition they're like
I don't even want to do this why am I
doing this I have so much other stuff
going on I got a drive an hour to Santa
Monica sit in the room for three seconds
and then drive an hour back it's a waste
of time but then you do it and then you
meet that person and they remember you
six months down the road I mean it
happens more than people probably
realize really that they give your name
to somebody else and you know there you
go
or someone heard of good things that I
always coming from I worked in casting
and it's like if I know somebody that
can do the role and I know them
personally and I've seen them do great
work and they're awesome be with on set
and I know they'll show up and give it
their all we're gonna go ahead and cast
them as opposed to open it up to 3,000
submissions for other people just
because we already have it right there
in front of us you know that's just
that's me and kind of you know on a much
smaller scale and the bigger stuff
obviously but I think that does kind of
trinkle its way up to the top as well
that type of a lot of the same people
are always working and really that's
what you see the same person in like
nine commercials in a row just for
people like working with them and
they're good at what they do
you